un tsunami de lava con esa expresión
varios expertos han descrito la
actividad volcánica en la isla de la
palma que lejos de acabarse se ha
acelerado en los últimos días casi un
mes después de su inicio a eso se
sumaron dos sismos de magnitud 45 los
más fuertes desde el comienzo de la
erupción hace 26 días en este escenario
tener un panorama claro de la situación
resulta difícil para las autoridades
ahora mismo con esta situación nos
resulta a veces complicado para
hacer estudios de la zona porque hemos
perdido los puntos de referencia antes
tenías carreteras calles lugares
emblemáticos y ahora ha quedado todo
completamente desdibujado la lava se lo
ha comido todo y
y no tenemos ya esos puntos de
referencia el jueves otras 300 personas
debieron ser evacuadas elevando el total
a 7000
organizaciones como world central
kitchen una ong fundada por el chef josé
andrés se han acercado a asistir tanto a
los afectados como a las fuerzas de
seguridad y asistencia para todos en la
crisis se está prolongando más de lo
esperado muchas veces es emocionante
conocer antes
sensaciones están a prueba de pierce
otros canales al esfuerzo cada vez hay
más gente cercana a nosotros le vas
implicando más con la gente yo llevo ya
cuatro semanas en ti pero yo venía para
dos días y revolvía bagaric y al final
diego ya más de cuatro semanas aquí
hasta el momento no ha habido reportes
de muertes en la isla de 85 mil
habitantes pero la lava ha destruido más
de 1500 edificios en la mayoría de ellos
viviendas y cubrió más de 680 hectáreas
produciendo gases tóxicos cuando alcanza
el mar